one of the right baseball minds that I
worked with that the mothership he Steve
Phillips host of leadoff spot on MLB
Network and Sirius XM former Mets GM he
joins us on the program
Steve full disclosure I heard you on Mad
Dog radio this morning coming in and I
said you know what Steve is making some
nice you know concrete bite-sized
answers here given opinions on both
sides of this and I thought you know
what let me have him come on and
summarize exactly what is going on with
Major League Baseball right now so
thanks for joining us on short notice
and it's great to see you glad to be
here and obviously these negotiations
going on baseball made their proposal
and it was effectively a non-starter for
the Union the idea of the sliding scale
and I think the way to look at it is
owners have proclaimed that they're
gonna lose 40% of the revenues without
fans in the stands that includes ticket
sales concessions parking all of that
that it's 40% the proposal they made to
the players on taking a pay cut off of
the prorated salary is a sliding scale
that impacts guys differently depending
upon how much money they make
but effectively on average they're
asking the players to take a 33 percent
pay cut now so effectively the 40% loss
they're actually putting 33% of that on
the players and only holding 7% of that
themselves from the owners perspective
so it's a non-starter for the players
they don't like the sliding scale and
the way it's sort of spread out and so
the Union now looking to put together a
counter proposal that we're hearing is
going to be prorated salaries that's it
and we want more games and from the
owners perspective they're looking at it
saying we lose about six hundred eighty
thousand dollars per game paying
prorated salaries without fans in the
stands more games is worse for the
owners and it pushes the regular-season
deeper into the fall where the owners
have a real concern that they might lose
the playoffs with the second wave of the
virus and the playoffs is the biggest
line item of revenue for owners right
now that playoff share of the network
money they can't put that at risk and so
therein lies the problem in this
negotiation all right let me make you
the mediator here you're gonna bring
both sides together what is the common
ground
that will allow us to be able to play
baseball right so the first thing the
players need to understand is the owners
perspective there's two things one not
having fans in the stands is a major
issue when it comes to revenues that
needs to be addressed that a player
getting a hundred percent of his day's
pay when the owners getting sixty
percent of revenue that's the problem
the players need to acknowledge it and
they have to get off of the prorated
salaries the other thing the players
need to understand is that if they're
going to get paid the owners are going
to pay them upfront and then make them
self whole by collecting the play off
money if the play offs don't happen then
it's catastrophic losses for the owners
so the players need to protect the
owners with the risk of losing the
playoffs from the owners perspective
they need to understand for the players
that prorated salaries already cripples
them at half their pay and taking less
than that with where they are and the
fact they have short term lifespan as a
baseball player that ultimately they're
the ones going on the field taking the
physical risk that has dollar value that
needs to be acknowledged and so
ultimately the two sides need to
understand prorated salaries and 100%
will not get a deal done the players
gonna have to come off of that and the
owners are not going to get a 50/50
share of the losses with the players
because they're taking physical risk and
the owners can make it up in the future
by just making different business
decisions next year and they could have
expansion a couple years from now where
they could have a billion dollar
franchise fee and make themselves whole
in a significant way so the middle
ground is get off of the prorated
salaries but the owners are not going to
get a 20% 20% split on the 40% loss it's
going to be players take a 10% reduction
in your prorated salary but you're going
to have to defer some of that money and
it will be paid contingent upon whether
we have the playoffs or not and if we
get there you get the full share of a
10% pay cut off your prorated salary we
make a deal we move on I wonder about
this looking back on the NFL deal that
the owners in player struck and what I
thought the Players Association did
Brill
was play to the guys that aren't making
a lot of money we're gonna get you
benefits here therefore they were gonna
get the votes they needed to have this
pass you have the haves and the
have-nots and it feels like Mike Trout
or Max Scherzer those guys are taking
the biggest financial haircut where is
it feels like the owners or the
commissioners playing to the guys who
are making minimum here like these guys
have to come back Mike Trout or Max
Scherzer they don't have to come back is
there going to be a war between the
haves and the have-nots inside the
players associations right so you're a
hundred percent right now I don't
believe that that was the owners purpose
okay in their offer to split the union
but it could have been a residual impact
of it now it could backfire on them
because 65 percent of the players make
between the minimum salary and 1 million
dollars those players under the owners
proposal will play half the season 50%
of the season and get 46% of their pay
they're not damaged that significantly a
guy like Mike Trout is gonna play half
the season and get 22% of his pay and so
that feels there's like an injustice
there but 65% of the players are pretty
safe I gotta tell you I think the
players are more tightly United than
what the owners gave their credit for
now I know you got a lot of guys out
there talking and they may not be as
united from their leadership to contain
themselves but I don't think there's any
player that's gonna look at Mike Trout
and say yeah you're 36 million should
turn into 7 million this year and you
should take the bulk of the pay back to
the owners and all of this and so I
think there's gonna have to be a reek
that's why I think the players response
to the owners proposal will be like yeah
that's a nice offer
we don't care anything about that our
counter proposal is not going to work
off of your system your format your
structure we're gonna come at you
completely differently with our proposal
yeah but I'm concerned about we're
talking to Steve Phillips a host of MLB
radio network on Sirius XM I'm concerned
about when you start to look at this
with guys wanting to come back this is a
star driven league I mean we do show up
for Clayton Kershaw
or you know Aaron judge or Mike Trout if
they're not coming back the guys who
make all this money are people gonna be
that starved to say hey I'm okay with
watching the Phillies without Bryce
Harper here did they run the risk of
that Steve yeah I think they do I think
I think the risk exists and and yet you
know the other four other reasons they
still might make a deal as some players
might not play Mike trout's wife's
expecting a baby and the notion of you
know does he put himself at risk and his
wife and baby at risk Garret Cole's
wife's expecting a baby they're the two
highest-paid guys out there so that does
I think players will play and if they
don't I felt think I still think it's a
compelling enough product that you're
gonna get players to show up and play if
fans are gonna watch because I'm
desperate we're desperate to be able to
watch some live for sports here in the
States
yeah I just wonder how this goes
horribly wrong and and baseball has to
know its place in sports society this
sports landscape here and I think that
that it feels tenuous Steve it does I
look I and I think that this negotiation
is not exclusive about to the 2020
season we've got a collective bargaining
agreement that's due to expire at the
end of 2021 that's just on the horizon
if and there's a high level of distrust
which I thought we had made up a lot of
ground with labor peace for a long
period of time but man we went right
back to the Hatfields have been toys
here I mean it has gotten ugly right out
of the get-go and the players don't
trust the owners numbers when the owners
say it's gonna cost us 40% the players
like okay let's show us the books and
the owners have never just showed the
books now the owners may be telling the
truth that it's 40% of their revenues
but it doesn't necessarily mean it's
going to be a 40% loss because some part
of that 40% might be coming out of some
of the profits that they were making and
so it might turn in a 40% loss of
revenue might be a 20% loss this year
and so the players max scherzer came out
and said we're not coming off prorated
numbers unless you show us the books if
you show us the books we'll make it
public and then we'll go along with it
and he thinks the reason the owners
don't want to do it is that they're
telling it I got to tell you but Dan
having been in the front office for
thirteen years I never saw the second
set of books if there's two sets of
books the way we set it up with the Mets
was we did we we set up the breakeven
we projected revenues work backwards off
of that as to what payroll could be
minor-league expenses scouting expenses
and self to break-even if we won and
what to the playoffs we made money and
if we lost and we were losing money we
traded guys in the dead line try to get
back to break-even there wasn't the
secret set of books with the the super
saw somewhere that they're hiding money
I never saw it if there were those set
of books you of course we're the gym
with the Mets with the Bobby Bonilla
deal and I'm wondering is I think it
allowed you guys to sign Mike Hampton is
that fair to say it freed up some money
but if you look back on that deal would
you make that deal again with Bobby
Bonilla yeah so remember we're releasing
Bobby Bonilla and and ownership said you
know that his group his agency had
represented Darryl Strawberry back in
the day where they had done deferred
compensation and but yeah people don't
know this when he first signed with the
best the first time around he had
deferred compensation with them too he
still get some payments from that first
deal he made with the Med Center
compensation and so you know here's the
thought on that though was the Mets
looked at at a time is we had Bernie
Madoff as an investment vehicle so the
Mets looked at the furry Bonilla as
compensation as a way for the team to
make money that they were going to take
his I think of 6.8 million or whatever
that number was release him and then
invest that money with Madoff and put it
out for ten years not paying anything
and then spread it out over 25 years of
payments of equal payments in the end so
I would just tell hey give it to the
county department level crunch numbers
and if Madoff returned this percentage
or that percentage of that percentage
how much money would he make on bumi is
money and the notion was that we had a
chance to make millions on his deal even
with the payout for Bonilla over that
period of time and so quite honestly it
was turning what was a loss of 6.8
million in a single year of releasing
him into what would be a win and a
financial windfall for the organization
because of the Madoff investments did
you invest in Madoff great you know what
is funny I I actually you know what
was suggested say you know you get some
money saved up we can maybe get you an
account with birdie and I ask the
question what makes him better than
everybody else like why is why is he
better like why don't people just look
at what he's doing and other people sort
of copy his investments and do it and
when I stole was he keeps everything
really close to the best obviously and
in that it but here's the thing like
Fred Wilpon you know once Fred Wilpon
vetted you he loved you and like I was I
was in their group like he like I was
one of his people that he really treated
me with love and respect and Bertie was
a friend of his let's that's why Fred
had no idea because when they had me go
and have the accounting department run
the money they said you know if he makes
what if he loses some money some here so
they did a whole number of iterations on
it and ran it through the system without
any expectation of what the return would
be just knowing that he was better than
others and they might get a return on it
so it was heartbreaking because for the
will ponds knowing Fred it was the
relationship I've seen lost a lot of
money but the relationship and that sort
of commitment and connection he had was
really devastate was heartbreaking for
me to see all of that and go through
that from the outside looking in at that
point but the aftershocks of that
relationship between the will bonds and
Bernie Madoff is that why the Mets are
up for sale or been up for sale you know
by the way I never ended up investing
but I think that you know that was part
of where they'd been but you know I
don't know I think sometimes what we see
with ownership is the succession plan
right when the owner gets a little bit
older how do you you know the estate
taxes on a franchise we saw it back in
the day I guess with the Robbie family
down in Florida they're selling the team
and you know how do you then pay those
taxes on the ownership of it and so I
think that there's some part of maybe
the planning for a succession plan
that's coming into it but you know
here's thing if expansions may be coming
and that may be a way for owners to
solve their problem right
put billion dollar expansion fees for
two new franchises to come in to get you
to 32 which would balance it out then
they can sort of subsidize themselves
like they did back in the 90s to pay off
the collusion payment and settlement
when they added you know the Rockies the
Marlins back in the day so
so I think that they you may see the
Mets hold out a bit if expansion is just
around the corner where are we going to
expand to well I think Montreal seems
like a potential place Portland is a
possibility I think San Antonio I didn't
know the San Antonio what the 7th most
populated city in the country I'm 1.5
million in the city you know I think
that Nashville is a place that people
are talking about is possibility
Charlotte and the notion is you know and
there's been this thought that Tampa and
Oakland need to be resolved first right
you've got to stadium issues there the
Oakland A's can't even pay their rent
right now by the way 1.2 million dollars
have not paid the rent for this season
but the thought all along has been
you've got to resolve those two before
you expand but I think you could find 28
owners right now who would vote to
expand before worrying about what to do
with Tampa Bay in Oakland if it's going
to generate the expansion fees that
could come with it to try to make
everybody whole after the suffering
financially from this pandemic great
Stubbs Steve I hope you're doing well
and we appreciate you joining us my
pleasure thanks for having me that's
Steve Phillips host of MLB Network radio
on Sirius XM